so you also write
i think let's go back to the brain you
write that plato gave us the idea
that the human brain has three brains in
it three forces
which is kind of a compelling notion uh
you disagree
first of all what are the three parts of
the brain
and uh why do you disagree
so plato's description of the psyche
which for the moment we'll just assume
is the same
as a mind there are some scholars who
would say you know a soul a psyche a
mind those aren't actually all the same
thing in ancient greece but
we'll just for now gloss over that so
plato's idea was that
and it was a it was a description of
really about moral behavior and moral
responsibility in humans
so the idea was that you know the human
psyche can be described within
um metaphor of
two horses and a charioteer so one horse
for instincts like
feeding and fighting and fleeing and
uh reproduction i'm trying to control my
salty language
um which apparently they print in
england like i
actually tossed off of foreign
yeah i was like you printed that i
couldn't believe you printed that
without like the stars or whatever
no no no there was full print yeah they
also printed
the a b word and it was really quite
yeah
anyways we should we should uh learn
something from england
indeed anyways but instincts and then
the other horse
represents emotions uh and then the
cherry tier represents rationality which
controls
you know the two beasts right and um
fast forward you know a couple of
centuries
and uh in the middle
of the 20th century there was a very
popular view
of brain evolution which suggested that
you have this reptilian core
like a lizard an inner lizard brain
for instincts and then wrapped around
that evolved
on layer on top of that evolved a limbic
system
for uh in mammals so the novelty was in
a mammalian brain
which uh bestowed mammals with
uh gave them emotions the capacity
promotions and then
um on top of that evolved
a cerebral cortex which
in in largely in
primates but but very large in in humans
um
and it's not that i
personally disagree it's that as far
back as the 1960s but
really by the 1970s it was shown pretty
clearly
with evidence from molecular genetics so
peering into
cells in the brain to look at the
molecular makeup of genes that the brain
did not evolve that way
and the irony is that
um you know the the idea of
the the three-layered brain with an
inner lizard you know that
hijacks your uh hijacks your behavior
and causes you to do and say things
that you would otherwise not or maybe
that you will regret later
that idea um became
very popular was popularized by
carl sagan in the dragons of eden which
won a pulitzer prize
in 1977 when it was already known pretty
much
in evolutionary neuroscience that the
whole uh
narrative was a myth so well the
narrative is on the way it evolved
but do you i mean again it's that
problem of
it being a useful tool
of conversation to say like there's a
lizard brain
and there's a like if i get overly
emotional on twitter
that was the lizard brain and so on uh
but do you no i don't think it's useful
i think it's a
i think that is it is is it uh is it
useful is it accurate
i don't think it's accurate and
therefore i don't think it's useful
so here's what i would say you know i
think that
um the way i think about
philosophy and science
is that they are useful tools for living
and in order to be useful tools for
living
they have to
help you make good decisions
the triune brain as it's called this
this three-layer brain the idea that
your brain is like an already baked cake
and uh you know the cortex cerebral
cortex is just layered on top like icing
the idea that idea is the foundation
of uh the law in
most western countries it's the
foundation of
uh economic theory and
it largely and it's a great narrative it
sort of fits our intuitions about
how we work but it also
um it's in addition to being wrong
it lets people off the hook for uh
for nasty behavior you know um and it
also
suggests that emotions can't be a source
of wisdom
which they often are um in fact you
you would not want to be around someone
who didn't have emotions that would be
that's a psychopath right i mean that's
not someone you
you know want to want to really uh have
have that person deciding your outcome
so i guess my
and i could sort of go on and on and on
but my point is that
um i don't think
i don't think it's a useful narrative in
the end
you